[Music]
european
[Music]
it's
l
with new resources and enhanced
responsibilities
this new agency will guarantee
meaningful solidarity to european
governments
the new agency will give practical
support to governments for more
effective asylum procedures
including help with the relocation and
transfer of asylum seekers to different
european countries there will be no more
delays in getting the necessary support
to be sent in the member states facing
pressure
[Music]
within the eu it's high time that we
talk more about protecting people than
protecting borders and therefore we do
not only need frontiers we really need
the european agency for asylum to make
sure compliance with fundamental rights
and with real access to our european
asylum system
we made sure the new agency will have a
fundamental rights officers to monitor
what happened on the ground
this will guarantee all the rights and
dignity people deserve in our asylum and
reception system to that extent the
european asylum agency is a landmark
agreement that gives us the momentum to
create a system for european asylum
built on solidarity
you